according to recent study 40% of people
have experienced financial loss due to
procrastination in today's episode
you're not going to talk about why we
procrastinate I'll give you many reasons
why we do but at the end of it which is
a most important part of this episode
I'm going to explain to you when we're
about to procrastinate in our mind we go
through four different options and then
we just say I'm not gonna be doing it
why do we go there and once I talk about
that with you you'll get a new hack on
how to minimize the level of
procrastinating you're doing today so
this the first time you're visiting
vitam and this is the number one channel
on YouTube for entrepreneurs we got over
a thousand videos on this channel on
sales entrepreneurship hiring firing
raising money great interviews if you
haven't yet subscribed to the channel
please do so click on the subscribe
button and you can watch a bunch of
other videos afterwards anyways let me
get right into it point number one is a
bad estimation of time here's what I
mean by this so think about it this way
procrastination means you have a
deadline that you don't hit right you're
like I gotta get to this deadline it's a
priority but I don't hit it many times
you think you have a lot more time than
you really do right like think about it
you like arm you know I got next Friday
it's good I got so much time to get it
done all of us and you're like it's
Thursday oh my goodness how do I get
this thing done now maybe we got away
with it in high school maybe we got away
with it in college you cannot get away
with it in business because again you
don't hit your deadline you lose
customers you don't hit your deadlines
you lose millions potentially billions
some companies do because they don't
meet their deadlines so number one is
time optimist or somebody who has a bad
estimation of time number two you are
overwhelmed because you're taking on
more projects than you can handle let me
explain to what I mean by this I got a
big staff here a lot of people that work
at the home office a lot of salespeople
a lot of sales officers right and many
times if I look at somebody that every
time I ask him for something they say
yes or I got it okay yes yes yes I got
it yes I got it and then they don't need
half the deadlines I'll sit down with
them and I'll say listen you seem a
little overwhelmed you kind of tell
they're kind of going like this oh I got
it you know I got it and they're kind of
like sweating it right I'll say look I
want to simplify something for you
what's that just because I asked you to
do something doesn't mean you can't
rebuttal and tell me Pat I got these
three pending projects that are doing do
today and you
Smita to do it so which of these three
is less important than the next request
you just made then i backtrack and i
have to tell them you know what those
three our priority
do that i'll ask this either from
somebody else or let's revisit this
tomorrow no problem thanks Pat and then
they go back to their business right so
sometimes you're procrastinating because
you took on way more than you can handle
that's number two let's talk about
number three distractions what is
distractions way too many distractions
in your life for example this is a phone
okay we all have a phone but here's a
question what notifications are on on
your phone meaning snapchat insta
Twitter Facebook text whatsapp how many
notifications do you have do you know
how many of the reasons why we progress
is because all these notifications are
on sometimes you've got to turn off the
notifications to a lot of things you're
not being distracted a lot of different
things by the way there used to be time
where nobody could call their spouse at
work nowadays it's a little bit more
lenient that's not really that big video
like it used to be people talk to their
wives or their husbands while they're at
work but sometimes your biggest
distraction is every time your wife or
your husband has an issue you on the
phone with them oh my gosh babe what
happened Oh seriously oh my gosh okay
got it
and then you just forgot the project
that you were due by four o'clock today
and you miss your deadline then you're
sitting in a meeting you don't have
anything prepared looking like a fool
just because you got a call from your
husband and your wife and you got
distracted okay so sometimes it's you
have way too many distractions you got
to lower those number four you're
perfectionist sometimes when you're
perfectionist you don't do anything
unless if it's perfect right so you have
the I don't want to say best of both
worlds it's more like the worst of both
worlds because you're both scared a fear
of success and you're scared of fear of
a you know failure what if I don't do a
good job because it has to be perfect
and what if I do come through and do a
very good job then there's more pressure
on me because everybody's expecting me
to do another project that could be
bigger oh my goodness this is so crazy
and that whole pressure being a
perfectionist you just kind of set it
aside saying I'm just not gonna be doing
it so I'm afraid of failure or I'm
afraid of success I know this sounds
weird but some of you guys are related
to say that's exactly me Pat I
understand I've worked with many of you
you got to kind of get over this
perfection of stuff and start meeting
your deadlines point number five you
really don't know where to start and you
are told here's your task you got to get
this done
you said yes but you're not really clear
on what's expected of you so when you
come back to your desk or you're sitting
by your side like what is my step number
one or number two what do I do next I
have no idea what to do next so because
you wouldn't give a clear expectation
because you didn't ask the right
question you're sitting there saying I
don't really know my first step is what
do I do next so because you don't know
what to do next you procrastinate point
number six is low energy some people
call it lazy some people kind of low
energy stamina fatigue endurance
whatever you want to call it is I'll
give a task to somebody and you kind of
know they're like oh okay alright so let
me see if this is we had a meeting the
other day and I told my executives
there's a couple people in the office if
I ask for him to do a task in my mind I
know it's not gonna get done so why
don't we have them over here well let's
find a way to rearrange them you want to
move somebody else to another department
that they're not gonna get the job done
because every time they do their energy
is low and they're not excited by
heating hitting their deadlines why are
we moving somebody told the front
department no no no no we just have to
figure out to realize are we willing to
lower standards and accept this kind of
performance or do we need to go get
somebody with high energy that's not
lazy that's willing to work and get the
job done let's figure this thing out now
that may sound harsh to some people but
in reality if you're in an environment
that's a start-up and everything is
moving as somebody is low energy
sometimes you just don't get the
deadlines done because your energy is
just slow and you got to increase your
energy point number seven is very simple
it's boredom a lot of times you're given
a project or you accept a project or you
take an assignment or it's something for
yourself and you're trying to get this
one thing done this task then you got a
deadline you just kind of send you're
like oh my gosh I cannot believe I have
to do this you want me to pay my bills
on time this is so flippin boring it's
driving me nuts
I just don't want to deal with the
writing you set it aside right due to
boredom now that doesn't mean that's the
right decision you made but sometimes we
procrastinate because whatever project
we're working on is absolutely boring
point number eight your leader your
example procrastinates
so do you you're in an office as many
offices have a culture of
procrastination like no one really takes
deadlines that seriously no one really
takes projects that seriously I know
this sounds kind of strange but there
are many businesses that are ok
deadlines are not met they're very
casual about it so guess what happens if
that's the culture from the top and it
accepted anybody else in that culture is
okay with procrastination point number
nine you do not have the right team to
delegate to let me explain to what I
mean by this so your CEO your founder
your c-suite executive say you have
seven deadlines to reach this month okay
you got all these projects and three of
them it's gotta be you your diligence on
them but the other four you can delegate
to somebody else now every time it comes
down to you delegating a project to
somebody you either don't trust the
individual to be able to do as good of a
job as you or you just don't have the
right person so either you got to start
to learn to trust your people or go
recruit and find the right people that
you can trust because one of those two
is preventing you from delegating and
last but not least point number 10 you
simply don't see value in the project
you're working on meaning you're you're
you see the project you know you gotta
hit the deadline but you don't really
value so you just kind of say you know
what I'm not gonna be hitting it so I
procrastinate and you set it aside and
turn your attentions in a whole
different place so that is our 10
different reasons why we progress and
let's talk about how we come to
conclusion of our decision-making
process to say I'm gonna go up and come
through with this and not procrastinate
or I'm gonna procrastinate on this
project here's how simple it is when a
task comes to hand like we have to do
something our brain goes to one of two
places I don't know if I really want to
do this but on the other side is I have
no other choice I have to do this for
example I don't know if I want to wake
up this morning to go to the gym I
really don't feel like you don't have to
do it you get up to go to the gym
because you want to go to the gym and
get in shape and look better right now I
don't know if I really wake feel like
waking up this morning to take my kids
to school you don't have a choice you're
there right you have to get up early to
feed them and take them to school
because it's your job right so somebody
may watch is insane why don't if I like
the word have to hate to say to you a
lot of things in life is things we have
to do no one likes to pay taxes we have
to pay taxes no one you know likes to
take their kids to school every morning
you have to do it it's something no one
likes to go pay their bills but you got
to pay your bills you don't pay your
bills you kick that there's a lot of
things we have to no one wakes up and
says oh my gosh I love changing diapers
it's just the most exciting thing of my
life
I just love waking up to a bunch of
pooping diapers I love it but you have
to do it you're dependent you chose to
have a baby right so there's a level of
decision making process that has to do
with
your maturity level the higher we mature
there are certain things we got to do
that we don't want to do but we have to
do so let me get into a little bit
deeper you got four things that happens
every time you got a decision first
thing we think about here's a decision
here's a task here's a responsibility
that we got to take up number one do I
have to do it first thing your brain
will say no you don't have to do it or
it will say yeah you got to do it but
this one you can assign to the team we
can do collectively as a family we can
do collectively as an office it's a team
project I can make this a team project
or I can delegate this to an individual
to get this done right so no team
project delegate to an individual or yes
I'm gonna do it right the challenge with
a lot of the decisions that we
procrastinate on is things that we have
to do and things that it's on me to do
that we set aside that's when it causes
problems okay very simple it's stuff
that I have to do and it's mainly my
responsibility to do it that I said I
decide I don't want to really touch it I
don't really want to do this and then
the more of these things that stack on
top of each other then you have a
cluster of problems you got to be
working with so when it comes down to
procrastination a few things you've got
to be thinking about that I'll help you
out number one every time you have a new
project that comes to you first thing
you do is once you accept it make a list
of what you need to do next listicle so
for instance what do I need to do here
step number one do this number two is
this number three is this number four is
this number five is this number six is
this okay let me send that email number
one number two let me make that phone
call to this person number three I've
got to get that thing back and then I'm
good to go hey Johnny can you make that
phone call to Bobby get him on the phone
I got to talk to about this you're
already halfway to getting your
assignment done so you accept the
responsibility you take an assignment
instead of procrastinating immediately
make a listicle of what to do number two
create a reward system if I finish this
here's my reward some time it's very
simple you know if I get this part done
I'm going to go out there and go to this
place and eat if I get this part done
I'm going to go out there and do this if
I go and work out five days a week this
week on Sunday I'm going to go out and
get myself this if you read this book
every day for five days the kids are
gonna get this but there's got to be a
listicle and then there's got to be a
reward system add it to it then next
thing is to have smaller victories that
are getting you excited to develop the
muscle of getting projects done
sometimes you simply have a list and you
get
less done that builds confidence to know
like luck even this morning I made my
bed you know right after making my bed I
went to brush my teeth
I made something for my kids early in
the morning before I left man this is
good I got a lot of stuff done here it's
it's victories I'm getting small things
done so now when a bigger responsibility
comes you your muscles being built up
for this big one you get that part done
and that's a massive victory for you so
again listicle number one at a carrot to
it once you get it done create small
victories that lead to the big one and
last but not least the times where you
have to do something that you really
don't want to do there's a lot of
projects that I have to take as a
company that I really don't want to do
but I know it's getting me closer to the
vision always sell the vision to
yourself and the people involved in that
project for example guys listen I know
nobody wants to be doing this right now
we're here at 11 o'clock at night and we
got a lot of better things that we can
do them being here at 11 o'clock I'm
sure you'd love to be with your family
you probably would love to be Netflix
and chilling with your newest girlfriend
you'd probably love to be playing soccer
right now but here's what we're doing
afore the reality is this if we get this
together this projects gonna get us
closer to XYZ and you can get closer to
getting your promotion you can get
closer to doing this and collectively we
can say we were part of this project so
you do that both with your team and you
got to be able to psych yourself out too
when you're working on a project all by
yourself and nobody's there
if you don't psych yourself out when
you're by yourself on a project you're
working on that is I have to you'll
eventually get bored out of your mind
and you say you know what I'm just not
in the mood
so because the whole thing we talked
about would bore them earlier there's a
lot of things I do as a CEO on an
entrepreneur that's boring a lot of
things but because the vision is so big
and exciting and the legacy excites me
in the history excites me I do it
anyways based on the vision so again
those are the 10 reasons why people
procrastinate those are a few reasons
how we come up with our conclusion on
the decisions we make for
procrastination and a few hacks you can
use to help you minimize the level of
procrastinating you've been doing lately
and having said that the next video I
want you to watch is a video about you
deciding who is worth your time or not
we wrote a victim made a video called
who's worth my time it's a video for you
to process and decipher through all the
people you're spending time with to
I don't know why I keep spending time
with this guy you so every time I talk
to me just sucks out my energy I
shouldn't be spending time with this
person this video is built for you to
know how to prioritize your time and if
you haven't yet subscribe to the channel
please do so take everybody bye-bye